hey guys I'm Ryan Wright olicity crazy
we're gonna watch a trailer today for a
movie called
the boy next door advertised as a JLo
thriller JLo wait wait wait wait wait
wait a JLo thriller Jennifer Lopez
thriller that doesn't feel right to me
she used to meet like she did thrillers
in the past I don't think people will
take this seriously now
but this trailer was recommended by a
lot of people so who knows maybe it'll
be worth it
I don't like I like I like things like
made in Manhattan like she's good cutesy
character I just I can't see her in a
thriller it weirds me out oh she did
this one movie I forgot what it was
called but where she like learns how to
defend herself little fighting because
of her ex-husband it looks stupid I
never watched
she was an anaconda really her and Ice
Cube at the end by the end anyway yeah
this movie's rated R for violent sexual
content and nudity and language really
so you know what this sounds like it
might be worth someone's time oh okay
okay I'll roll with it I just think it's
a little weird there's only one way to
find out if we're still gonna be
interested we got to react to the trick
it's been nine months and you haven't
acted before yet sheets with the
secretary every time it goes through the
Havas yeah I'm a mistake you ready not
and you are no I'm staying next door way
from go-go
be not some ratchet no it was this ISIL
with my folks gonna finish up at Monroe
High Oh teaches action seemed too cool
to be a teacher I'm sorry I shouldn't
it's okay
the nicest thing anybody's said to me a
lot well then I'm glad I said you need
some real life just like to feel like
you owe me sister
just us you know I was feeling
vulnerable
I'm you thought I wasn't thinking
clearly can't do this
you know what you won't stay for dinner
hey mrs. Pearson don't miss meeting with
him oh they will there was a big
thunderstorm you guys did get it up
there Oh dry sparkly well it got pretty
wet here I like him right
I like him to have approved your request
no Sambora's on your class did you send
an email from my account
sounds like you've an act to change
password your father seems to be around
a run now huh
yeah I guess don't forget that he walked
out on you need you to stay away from
Noah okay see you at school
looks like job
my son
I can't do that when I live next door
do you want to take a cookie for the
road help you mother's cookies oh he's
pretty cool actually it does yeah it
looks pretty cool okay here's my one
concern but my only concern is it's a
January movie so this could be either
really good or one of the worst movies
of next year I don't know I feel like
it's gripping and I like I'm so
reluctant to say that because I don't
want to like JLo but now I kind of want
to like JLo and now I have mixed
feelings yeah she looks like she does a
really good job and I like I like the
story it's a kind of a brave story to do
cuz you know it's about it until
sleeping with a minor even though the
guy doesn't look like a minor you know
he's still under this plot of it he's
still underage and that's pretty funny
it's kind of funny because this is
developing a nurse I know yeah I like
the idea of like the obsession happening
you know cuz normally in a plot like
that it's like the guys either
traumatized or some [ __ ] but it's cool
that he's like liking it but then
becoming like darkly obsessed I think
that's really [ __ ] seems like it's
like a personality disorder yeah it
seems like even if it's bad it's gonna
still be thrilling at the same time
still gonna be entertaining no matter
what cuz it looks like a lot goes on it
doesn't look like it's just like a
boring a slow flick no no it actually
seems like it has a lot of action it
seems very fast-paced yeah that's why
I'm kind of intrigued because that's not
what JLo does like the result I just
wish there was a couple things they
didn't give away in the trailer
especially that scene that scene in the
school where all the photos are
everywhere in the classroom oh I don't
know that that seemed pretty cool you
know it's cool I just wish it I just
wish they didn't give it away why
because it's like that that could have
been a really like shocking powerful
moment in the movie yeah but that to me
just like that was the clarifying moment
where it's like oh dude this guy's a
psycho like Batman well it was pretty
obvious you circled yeah but not like
that that's extreme normally I like
making fun of the movies but I'm not
comfortable with pedophilia jokes okay I
agree a pedophile um yeah we're gonna be
rooting for the pedophile to get through
cuz it's an interesting story cuz she
did not do a good thing and she's
suffering the consequences of it yet
we're somehow gonna be on the journey
for her to get out of this
and I was her about decision yeah even
though she's the real bad person it's an
interesting kind of like they're both
sort of antagonists in a way you know
yeah
and I think that's really [ __ ] neat
and that's why I mean like it's kind of
brave and it's storytelling well yeah
thanks for letting me know that trailer
was out you know I had no interest in
watching it but that was actually a
pretty [ __ ] cool if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects where as I like to say we have a
lot of [ __ ] on there and alyssa has a
channel too
I you know she does like blogs and a
bunch of other stuff too challenges
challenges and soon but we should be
doing music and stuff so yeah you could
check out her channel too this is called
the very sincere recommendation on both
subscribe buttons so yeah you know
normally I try to crack jokes but I'm
just gonna be very sincere about it
today it's worth your time that's the
best policy yeah you know you don't want
to make it funny all the time you gotta
mix it up you know any moments of like
drama and stuff you know that's true
that's true let's do some shoutouts do
it Chris l'm Aris Ryan you [ __ ] Rock
you are funny as hell
shout out please Chris l'm Meera's thank
you very much
if anyone's funny in the room you're the
funny one you keep that comedy going my
friend don't ever stop making people
laugh remember rule of three you want to
build jokes like you want to build jokes
to make them cool you want to build
jokes to make them great you want to
build jokes in order for them to blossom
in the world and become something more
see one two three was the goofy one that
wasn't a good example but you know I
tried like meeting ground beef hell
you're a teaser joke well-rounded oh
okay that was a horrible joke done
learning from that don't learn anything
from that Amir Bey Roger Elissa is hot
Dan cybers a thought can i have a shout
out what does that mean that means
you're hot and that's all that matters
about that statement and so yeah Alyssa
I specifically saved this guy for you
this wasn't my chance Amir babe Roger
thank you ever so much
yeah man Amir Bey Roger
Roger that sounds like a type of creepy
like sex thing you know like Cleveland
steamer or angry pirate you know those
are no Cleveland steamer is like I
correct me if I'm a little bit off on
this but it involves [ __ ] on the
girl's chest
oh no no no no angry pirate now is where
you come in a girl's I know then you
kick them in the knee that way they
wronged you it's not me who invented
this but you know it you're damn right I
do
and a big Roger is when you dip your
testicles into the girl's mouth and then
urinate in the air past her head to make
it look like a fountain ah that's a baby
Roger just invented it this is get this
episodes of making history right yeah
Alex Scott loved the vids man can i have
a shout out dude Alex we love you we do
so that's where the love really counts
is between us as human beings as us as
people
it can transcend the internet France and
high and far distance and distance
that's something that is something
I'm still stuck on the whole Bay Roger
Judy oh that was pretty [ __ ] cool
that's like I just came up with a sex Oh